guys i'm freaking out man i'm freaking
out i gotta go to the dentist today
i don't like the dentist i was already
there last week i cracked a tooth not
too long ago and now i gotta go and get
the process completed
jenna's driving me i'm scared jenna said
if i was a good girl we can go to the
lego store and i can get myself a toy
i did yes are you gonna buy it for
yourself yes
you just have to take me jenna's driving
me because i'm afraid that i'm not gonna
drive back because i
i oh god honestly it's gonna be fine
i can't i joined it on friday i was
freaking out and he's like you're gonna
be fine my first question to him was am
i gonna die he's like no
you're not gonna die and i'm like are
you sure are you sure okay we gotta go
we gotta go
then this time
[Music]
i don't want to go i don't want to go i
don't want to go i don't want to go i
don't want to go
you're an adult yes but i'm not
yeah you are i'm not here it's gonna be
fine we're gonna go to the lego store
after
we're gonna have um i'm gonna get i'm
gonna get a mini figure i'm not allowed
to buy it i told her she's not allowed
to get us it's like i clicked
on my child i think i might be i'm not
going to get a lego set but i am going
to get myself a single minifigure which
one
well i don't know they're blind bags so
i don't know what i'm oh ooh blind bag
challenge
i'm gonna find that seven minutes
am i prepped am i prepped oh i'm feeling
silly
wish me luck guys
oh god is it not this one just go in
that one this one there's
two entrances how would i know which one
to go in guys i gotta go to the dentist
if i told you that yet i'm super
i'm super scared is anybody else afraid
of the dentist please tell me no i tell
them
nothing you get a ticket please take
your ticket
you can go ahead i'll wait i've got
nothing but time
not that much time i don't want to go
guys i don't want to go on being a baby
but
the last time i went i was just like
raise your hand if you feel pain and i
was raising my head for two seconds
[Music]
say goodbye to you too my tooth isn't
going anymore you don't know that
we're just hanging on
[Music]
i'm freaking out man i'm freaking out
guys i'm still alive i haven't died yet
she's getting a lego set i am getting a
like
you're gonna have to tell them i was i
was good i would tell them very good
you get a minifigure
things are going well everything's going
great
this is you okay so wait that's that's
right you want to see him yeah that huge
hole
that's huge yeah so that's
the hole that you came in with oh god
right so this is the x-rays that we took
that he took but yeah well kind of
you can kind of see it
do you see how there's a little shadow
right here yeah so it was there
like look at look at this tooth which is
healthy and then there so
is this where my fake teeth are yeah
fake thick yeah but you can see that
this one's starting to crack yeah oh for
sure
see it oh god we did it half my face is
still numb
thank you can you tell them i did a good
job she did great and she deserves
uh any lego set you want any lego sets
great i would suggest a real expensive
one to have your sister pay for well she
told me i have to buy it she's just
driving me there
we're very proud of you thank you you're
welcome and it wasn't even as bad as i
thought no see the dentist is good yeah
it's great six months
come regularly okay oh gosh
[Music]
did he come out and tell you i did a
good job what did he say
she's getting the lego set oh
god i said that you were only going to
get me a minifigure and that's all i was
allowed
and i'm buying it anyway you're fine
you're just trying to be fair
i get the call it's like i need help
listen i'm appreciative and half my face
is not as happy is it moving or is it
not moving the elevator is moving
it's moving do you guys remember when i
got my wisdom teeth out
yes i was kind of hoping that this is
what the content would be like this
isn't fun
i'm sorry well i didn't get put out
l no lego do you guys remember when i
went on steve harvey and showed him how
to use snapchat spectacles
because if you don't it was a thing that
happened
[Music]
i haven't seen you since e3 can't wait
can't feel my face i can't feel my face
when i'm with myself
[Music]
this has to be it okay i think this is
the bread with a dog
i think this is the corn man
what is this what could that be
oh that's that wasn't the pie it was his
hat oh you guys got the mystery
guy yes okay i got the dog okay perfect
that's the one i wanted
one and i'm hoping this is the corn yes
yes yes yes yes oh god i'm so hyped i
got two of the minifigures that i wanted
and we're gonna have to come back
because we don't want to get stuck in
traffic heading back home
so now we're gonna do some light
shopping possibly get a coffee
i still can only feel half of my face
are we doing something tonight yeah
eating dinner and packing for vegas
oh my god we're going to vegas tomorrow
holy moly
hello how's it going we've got a we've
got something to watch
wait do i have to watch the whole 30
minutes no this is the three minute
version
she's out here in this wonderful winter
wonderland no
i don't want to go nice here thank you
did dad thank you he did i don't want to
do this look at your little outfit
i got my uggs on you doing okay that was
quick procedure
it's small for your friends oh my gosh
it wasn't too though look good
i don't think they took it out they took
it out
how many teeth did you get out i don't
know i think just one
i got three taken out i only had one i
wish at the time
i made videos because i got three taken
out
i swear
he has a
i'll see if they can find it they
already threw it away
[Laughter]
i was so upset i wanted it for the tooth
fairy
you have your phone you should be your
phone that's something
about yeah millennials
okay even though you took it okay
i told you it wasn't that bad did you
look at your little left
nope nope okay it was so good
you
that's what we're talking
oh my god oh my god oh no i can't walk
you can't basically he showed me the two
look at it
oh look at that that's very nice
look at that
[Music]
you made them pull that out of the truck
i did i refused to leave
unless they showed me that too they
could have pulled out anyone's tooth to
be like yeah here it is this is yours
well guys that was that i gotta go back
to get the final
crown on sometime next in a few weeks so
jenna stay tuned
what what you're still talking about
you go again all right we'll see you
guys later thanks for watching um
be nice to your dentists be nice to
everyone i forgot to show them i already
showed them the legos i got i'll show
you them tomorrow in the next video yeah
you can see them
i recorded the wait no i recorded it as
well
i was gonna go check out my channel i
was gonna go put them together i gotta
go to bed it's late okay bye
[Music]
you